well we do want to say here it is we're
officially one week away from the 2020
general election
so far more than 258 000 people in clark
county
have turned out for early voting a news
now reporter kate houston spoke to the
election department
about some of the top questions they're
getting from voters
with only a few days left of early
voting some community members came out
to silver mesa recreation center to cast
their ballot
dan kulin with the election department
says while the polls have been busy
so have the phone lines the county's 455
vote hotline is receiving more than 2
thousand calls a day
voters can call basically with any
question
it's a good starting point for folks who
are looking for information
some top questions from voters are if
they're allowed to vote in person after
receiving a mail ballot and where they
should go
years ago we had assigned precincts we
had to go to a very specific polling
place that was near our house
but we've changed that and so now any
voter in clark county can vote at any
polling place on election day just like
in early voting
registration is another question they
get so far
more than 1.2 million nevadans are
registered to vote in this election
we do have same-day registration in
nevada
and so if folks aren't registered to
vote they still can register at their
polling place
when it comes to mailing your ballot
kulin says it has to be postmarked on
or before november 3rd know that once
turned in
the decisions on your ballot cannot be
changed if they're going to be voting in
person
we would strongly suggest that they mark
their sample ballot
with their selections and then bring it
with them so that they can
you know use their sample ballot to make
sure they're making the choices they
want to make
early voting will last through october
30th kate houston 8 news now
in addition to the 400 or rather 455
vote hotline you can also go to the
election department's website
there is information on voting locations
registration and much more
that can be found at clarkcountynv.gov
vote denise